well the Democrats looking to succeed
President Trump are focusing on Iowa
this weekend with three months to go
before voters in the Hawkeye State cast
their ballots a new poll finds
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
in first place among Democratic voters
in Iowa she's followed by Bernie Sanders
Pete Budaj eggs and Joe Biden ed O'Keefe
is in Des Moines this morning Edie good
morning good morning this weekend is an
important turning point on the road to
2020 some campaigns are shutting down
others are scaling back and everyone
agrees Iowa is critical which is what
made a big event here last night so
important this is a moment where we have
to be prepared to fight for the best of
our country we can't just win we have to
win bit a three-month sprint to the Iowa
caucus began with a final gathering of
Democratic contenders with the race
tightening there's a clear contrast
between moderates and liberals we will
fight when we must fight but I will
never allow us to get so wrapped up in
the fighting at a time of massive income
and wealth inequality the Democratic
Party must become the party of the
working class of this country shortly
before the rally former Congressman
pedal Aurora
once said he was born to be in the race
bowed out failing to break out of the
single digits while frontrunner
Elizabeth Warren finally answered a
question that's dogged her for months
how would she pay for her
government-backed health care plan we
can have medicare for all without
raising taxes one cent on middle-class
families instead Warren's plan would
divert the funds employers currently pay
private health care companies to the
government and increase taxes on the
wealthy with assets above a billion
dollars and it's all fully paid for by
asking the
1% and giant corporations to pay a fair
share on stage last night someone
opponents dismissed her new plans for 3%
of the cost of Medicare for all we could
cut childhood poverty by 40% that sounds
like a big idea to me build on the
Affordable Care Act not abandon it
that's why we have to provide a public
option that's why that's why we have to
make sure everyone has access everyone
seems to be driving hard but the
question is how much of a political
gamble is a little is above Warren's
medicare-for-all plan well it very well
could be you know you look at polling
for example that poll that came out just
yesterday that suggests that there are
more Iowans who would rather live in a
country where a government back plan is
an option than mandatory that they if
they wanted to keep their private health
care they'd be able to do so and that's
you know a debate that continues among
Democrats so now that she has this
payment plan out there it'll get picked
apart by voters especially in this state
but you know for one practical reason
think of this this city des moines many
of the buildings here are packed during
the week with thousands of people who
work for insurance companies and there
are questions about what would happen to
them for example if suddenly private
insurance went away and the government
was in charge and that's a question
Warren will have to continue answer yeah
des Moines and Hartford and both of
those big insurance cities let's go to
Kamala Harris now news that she's
scaling back operations in New Hampshire
so what should we make of this right
yeah CBS News has learned that she is
parting ways with most of her campaign
staff in New Hampshire and moving
essentially her entire operation here to
the Hawkeye State her campaign last
month made a pretty bold move bowing to
finish in the top three in this state if
that's the case she's got an uphill
climb because right now she's trailing
badly behind Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren Joe Biden and people to judge and
so much of the talk in Washington is
focused on the impeachment inquiry what
are candidates and voters saying on the
campaign trail well you know they
obviously if you talk to Democrats or
please
to see it happening say it should run
its course even if the Senate holds a
trial and ultimately decides not to
remove the president we spoke with a few
voters last night who said it will not
have been a waste of time it will have
been an exercise of the Constitution and
something that should play out but it's
going to be a potential practical
concern for the six senators who are
running for president who would have to
sit through that impeachment trial and
stay off the trail for a few days and
you look comfortable and in control in
Des Moines but we know it's freezing
somebody go get some hot coffee yet okay
thank you very much we'll do